servers are something that most people
never give much thought to they're
simply the background machines that make
the modern world go around but the world
of servers is actually far more
fascinating than you might think the
global server Market is worth 90 billion
and a lot of household names serve the
cloud and server markets as well this
includes Amazon Google Microsoft Dell
Oracle and Cisco with this many big
players you would think that the server
Market is cutthroat and extremely
competitive especially given that their
entire customer base is other
sophisticated companies as opposed to
the general public but what if I told
you that the server Market has also been
monopolized not by any one of the common
corporates like Google or Amazon but
actually IBM you see
96.3% of the world's top web servers all
use the same OS Linux for perspective
even Windows and Android only have a 70%
market share now traditionally Linux is
an open- Source operating system that
isn't owned by any one entity and is
completely free to use but this is not
the sort of Linux that companies use
instead companies prefer to use an
Enterprise version of Linux there are a
few options here including Ubuntu mint
and Fedora but one Dro rises above
everyone else Red Hat Red Hat Linux is
basically the default choice for
companies and large companies in fact
over 90% of the Fortune 500 uses some
sort of Enterprise solution from Red Hat
and for the longest time red hat was
just a background Shadow company that
the general public had no clue about but
4 years ago IBM decided to change that
by purchasing the entirety of red hat
for a cool $34 billion so now it's IBM
that controls basically the entire
Enterprise server OS Market but how did
we even get here how did one company end
up getting so much control over the
entire world's Tech
infrastructure well join me as we take a
look back at the Monumental rise of red
hat and the landmark deal that has put
IBM back on the
[Music]
map speaking of Legacy products making a
comeback a classic investment that's
making a comeback is B bonds you've
probably heard about stocks buying a
share of ownership in a company bonds
are a bit different you loan money to
governments and companies and they pay
you back with interest normally bonds
are seen as the boring investment for
old people because while they're
generally safer than Stock Investing
they also come along with low returns of
1 to 3% but this has all changed with
the new high interest rate environment
right now the US federal government
themselves are paying 5% for bills that
are as short as 1 month to bonds that
are as long as 30 years and companies
are paying even more so if you'd like to
lock in these high yields for yourself
for the short-term or longterm please
consider checking out our upcoming Bond
investing app Silo in the description
below but anyway going back to Red Hat
the story of red hat dates back 30 years
to a bum named Robert Young Robert had
huge Ambitions of running his own
company and making it big in the
business world but the reality for
Robert was that he was unemployed and
broke working on companies in his wife's
sewing closet his latest Endeavor was
running a computer supply catalog
business and to get the word out about
this business Robert would regularly
attend local Tech conferences and try to
network with as many people as possible
it was during one of these networking
events that Robert would run into a man
named Mark Ewing Mark was your classic
1980 software engineering geek he spent
his childhood Summers attending Compu
computer cams and writing programs for
Apollo and commodore computers within
his local community and especially at
College he was known as The Tech Guy and
given that he liked wearing red hats
people would begin referring to him as
the man in the red hat and the name
stuck Mark wasn't necessarily looking to
start a massive company like Robert
though in fact it seems like he
preferred the traditional pth as he
would turn around and get a job at IBM
after college in his free time though he
would continue meddling with side
projects like trying to cut customiz
Linux for Enterprise use this project is
what would lead Mark to the Fateful
conference where he met Robert Robert
would convince Mark to let him sell his
Linux dros through his new computer
supply catalog business and this marked
the beginning of a legendary partnership
at first it was simply a distribution
deal Robert would sell Mark link CDs but
Robert would end up selling out of these
CDs so often that he knew that Mark was
on to something so in 1995 the two would
decide to join en forces and to create
Red Hat software with Robert serving as
their first CEO despite forming a
company and having profit incentive
though the duo never really strayed away
from their Roots they didn't just go out
and file a bunch of patents and
trademarks instead they continued to
support the open source Community as
they believed that open collaboration
was the best way to create software this
turned out to be a great decision not
just from a community perspective but
from a reach perspective being open
source gave Red Hat to quite a bit of
notoriety within the Tech Community
leading to a lot more adoption in fact
by 1999 redhead would grow to just over
$10 million in annual revenue this was a
solid 8 fig business that was
realistically worth $3 to $50 million
but combine this with the dotcom bubble
and things would go insane they would
IPO with a share price of $14 but by the
end of the first trading day itself the
share price would rocket to $52 by the
end of the second day the share price
would rocket to $72 giving the company a
valuation of $4.8 billion Red Hat had
gone from being a company that Robert
ran from his closet to a multi-billion
dollar company within just a matter of
years it almost seemed too good to be
true and that's because it was moving
into the 2000s red hat would face an
existential crisis as the company came
back down to reality
[Music]
hard
the bottom line was that red hat was
extremely overhyped and overvalued at
least from a stock perspective and it's
no wonder why many investors Saw Red Hat
as the windows of servers and they
weren't wrong red hat did end up
becoming way more dominant than even
windows in terms of market share but
there's two major differences first of
all Microsoft was already way bigger
than just windows and two there was a
lot more money to be made in the
consumer market and when the market
realized this red hat stock would get
annihilated down to just $4 per share to
make things worse both Robert and Mark
would leave red hat in 1999 and 2002
respectively they didn't leave on bad
terms or anything they actually left on
satisfied terms sure they didn't become
the next Bill Gates or Steve Jobs but
they had already made hundreds of
millions each and they were ready to
enjoy life you can't really blame them
but they kind of did leave red hat and
all of its employees out to dry if all
of this wasn't bad enough red hat would
also start to see new competitors pop up
Seuss Linux Enterprise for example came
out in 2000 Ubuntu would come out in
2004 and Oracle would follow up with
their own version in 2006 the value
proposition of red hat was starting to
disappear despite them continuing to win
a bunch of awards for example they won
the operating system product of the Year
award four years in a row they would ALS
also be ranked number one for Value 2
years in a row but while Tech media
continued to be nice to Red Hat Red Hat
knew that they had to do something
different if they really wanted to stick
around they started thinking about their
Dro less as a piece of software and more
as a solution because well the software
itself doesn't give them a very big Moe
luckily for Red Hat everyone was already
using their software so the question
wasn't how do we get more customers but
rather how do we keep the customers that
we already have and from that
perspective it the answer was easy by
offering worldclass support support may
not seem like a big deal from a consumer
perspective but it's everything from an
Enterprise perspective keep in mind red
hat is what's keeping the entire Tech
infrastructure of companies like Google
and Amazon up and running and for
companies of this scale even 1 hour of
downtime is tens of millions of dollars
lost so keeping the back end in pristine
condition and getting immediate support
when when it's not is of utmost
importance this is actually quite ironic
given that support was something that
red hat initially neglected in fact in
the early days Robert would actually
joke about how the only way to reach Red
Hat support was through email which was
counterintuitive given that if your
computer needed support you probably
couldn't email in the first place but
moving into the 2000s red hat would
approach support from a completely
different perspective in fact they would
add a bunch of pricing tiers to their
software that were Direct linked to the
level of support that they came with and
let's just say this gets pretty
expensive as much as $2,500 per license
but with that being said most large
corporations view this as a necessity
and red hat very much does live up to
their price they truly do offer 24/7
first class white glove tech support
it's easy to spin off another Enterprise
version of Linux but matching the
support and presence of red hat is
extremely difficult and this made made
way for a new wave of prosperity for Red
[Music]
Hat after this change in approach red
hat would return to setting record after
record in 2009 they would be added to
the S&P 500 and just 3 years later they
would become the First open- Source
company to reach a billion in annual
revenue by 2015 they would reach $2
billion and by 2018 they would reach
nearly $3 billion Red Hat was no longer
the Boom story that it was back in the
9s by the late 2000s Red Hat was a
massive tech company offering critical
solutions to other massive companies
making billions in the process in the
business World though when a company
reaches extraordinary Heights it's only
a matter of time until someone else
wants a piece of the pie in the case of
red hat it was the worn down Legacy
giant IBM what IBM really needed was a
facelift a new way to appeal to and
attract customers because almost no
modern company really considered IBM as
a serious solution they all flocked to
AWS Azure Google and even Oracle Cloud
before they even considered IBM so IBM
decided to Target a different
demographic a more Legacy demographic
companies like Anthem American Airlines
Honeywell Panasonic deoe and Exxon
according to Arvin Krishna the CEO of
IBM most of these non-tech companies are
only about 20% converted to the cloud so
the idea behind buying red hat for $34
billion is that this would make IBM the
One-Stop shop for legacy companies who
just want a simple straightforward
reliable solution they don't need the
best performance or the fastest response
times or any of that all they wanted was
a stress-free migration to the cloud and
that's exactly what IBM was looking to
offer things have been working out
decently well from IBM's perspective but
many would argue that the same cannot be
said about red hat it's not that IBM is
purposefully making bad choices with red
hat or anything like that in fact you
could argue that IBM is genuinely trying
their best to respect the open source
niche of red hat while also trying to
improve IBM Cloud as much as possible
with that being said the problem seems
to be much more holistic and qualitative
many would argue that the bureaucratic
old school ways of IBM are simply
rubbing off on red hat and bringing down
the company much of red Hat's key
leadership left the company following
the acquisition and the people who are
left frankly only care about their own
compensation they don't know the users
and they don't care about the product
because they've never even used it this
has led to some really unpopular
decisions like pushing out unstable
upstreams with that being said though
this does seem to be more of a case of
incompetence as opposed to any sort of
malicious intent and as such we have yet
to see any sort of large scale movement
away from red hat but the vocal minority
has already started raising several
valid red flags and if IBM continues
running red hat in the same manner a
shift away from Red Hat may very well be
in the cards so the ball is really an
IBM's Court they've somehow been able to
covertly overtake an extremely powerful
piece of software but will they actually
be able to maintain red Hat's ubiquity
and dominance or will they fumble the
ball only time will tell the crazy part
is that this entire company wouldn't
even be possible without Linux if you'd
like to see how Linux came to check out
this video but until then I'm hurry and
I'll see you guys on the next
one